oh look adorable little minions and
these must be their masters evil
scientists actually these researchers
from the University of california-davis
are all right and so the minions really
we make little robots we put them out
the ocean we like to see where they go
these little robots are kind of like
kids there are my little minions unlock
you've seen the movie great movie the
robots are on a mission to unravel one
of the great mysteries of the sea what
the hell are marine larvae up to if you
were thinking hey that looks a lot like
a fire extinguisher painted yellow
you'll be right but the bots known as
able actually packs a whole lot of
technology so the robots are able to
move up and down on the water column by
taking oil and moving it between
internal and external bladder when they
move oil to the inside they sink and
when they move oil to the outside they
arise scientists have programmed them to
behave like swarms of larvae all the
while they measure things like depth and
temperature and salinity what the
revealing is that marine larvae may not
be drifting around kind of hopelessly in
the open ocean like previously thought
it may be that larvae are moving up and
down in the water column writing
different currents to stay fairly close
to shore so what's happening in the
ocean is the water is moving around a
lot but we need to be able to tell the
robot how to act accordingly and it can
use its buoyancy to maintain the death
or change def at certain times but we
need to be able to differentiate between
when the able is moving or when the
water is moving the able and we do that
by measuring its rotation using external
propellers but why bother studying
something so tiny it's because while
larvae may be small they're hugely
important understand marine larvae you
can better understand species many of
which are threatened by overfishing plus
plankton like larvae are extremely
sensitive to climate change and without
plankton all kinds of features like
whales wouldn't have food so swim on
little minions and stay out of trouble
you